se me ha pedido que realice otros vídeos
acerca de la derivación implícita de
hecho un joven llamado a casi me lo
pidió de una manera especial entonces
voy a realizar más de estos tipos de
vídeos esta vez voy a resolver un
problema que me pidieron que hiciera el
cual me parece muy interesante el
problema dice si deriva con respecto a x
la función y a kubica menos x por ye
cuadrada menos x por cuadrada ya esto
agréguele el coseno de xm el coseno de x
ya esto igual a loa 2 y bueno recuerdan
que yo lo que quiero es la derivada con
respecto a x de esta función por lo
tanto es una derivación implícita y si
yo estoy buscando una derivación
implícita entonces estoy atrás de la
derivada de ye con respecto a x por lo
tanto no olviden que yo lo que quiero es
la derivada de ella con respecto a equis
o ye prima como lo quieran llamar
entonces siguiendo con las líneas de lo
que hicimos en el vídeo pasado voy a
tomar el operador derivada con respecto
de ambos lados de la ecuación la
derivada con respecto a x de todo esto
es igual a la derivada con respecto a x
de 2 que a estas alturas ya deben de
saber que es cero
ahora bien voy a intentar hacer este
ejercicio de una manera mucho más rápida
aunque si ustedes sienten que fue muy
rápido dejen menos sus comentarios en
las notas de este vídeo bien calculemos
la derivada con respecto a x de kubica
bueno esto por la regla de la cadena
densidad deriva allí pública con
respecto a james y la derivada de que
kubica con respecto a ella pues es muy
sencilla es tres veces y cuadrada bien y
esto parece que el cuadrado ya esto
multiplicado por la derivada de que con
respecto a x es decir pues por la
derivada de ella con respecto a x que es
justo en lo que queremos la derivada de
ella con respecto a x
- y ahora hay que derivar x porque
cuadrada pero si se da en cuenta es una
multiplicación de funciones por lo tanto
voy a poner el signo menos y un
paréntesis para hacer la derivada de
esta multiplicación de funciones
entonces tomaré otro color no con este
mismo menos y voy a abrir unos corchetes
que digan a ver la derivada del primero
es decir la derivada de la primera
función ya esté que multiplicarla por la
segunda función y después hay que
agregarle la derivada de la segunda
función multiplicada por la primera
función tal cual entonces vamos a
hacerlo la derivada de x con respecto a
x pues es muy sencilla la derivada de x
con respecto de x es 1 entonces es uno
porque cuadrada ese va a ser mi primer
sumando uno porque cuadrada y después a
esto hay que agregarle la derivada de
cuadrada con respecto a x que ojo otra
vez por la regla de la cadena hay que
derivar con respecto a ayer que es 2
bien y después multiplicarlo por la
derivada de y con respecto a x y todo
esto por el primer término por la
primera función el cual la cual era x
217 x x x muy bien y entonces voy a
cerrar mis corchetes y revisemos si todo
está bien la derivada de x con respecto
de x es uno porque cuadrada ya esto hay
que sumarle la derivada de ya cuadrada
con respecto a x es decir torch derivada
de ye con respecto a x ya esto
multiplicarlo por x muy bien no hay
ningún problema ahora hay que sumarle la
derivada del po seno de x pero bueno
primero darse cuenta que la derivada del
coseno de una función esto creo que lo
voy a hacer mejores del lado derecho
para que quede mucho más claro lo que
estoy haciendo yo tengo la derivada del
coseno de quique es decir por la regla
de la cadena que voy a utilizar mucho la
regla de la cadera que recuerden que
decía la derivada de una composición de
funciones la habla bla bla bla ya haya
mostrado varias veces en general dice la
derivada del coseno de xy va a ser la
derivada del coseno que es el menos seno
pero el menos seno de quien a pues de la
función interior es decir el menos seno
de x
y después habría que derivar la función
interior es decir la derivada de x con
respecto a x bueno creo que tal vez
cuando lo ponga y lo escriba les va a
quedar mucho más claro pero pero bueno
vamos a escribirlo pareció intentar
cambiar de color y aquí voy a borrar
tantito esto para no confundirnos y voy
a hacer lo que estaba contando voy a
tomar supongamos que voy a hacer un
cambio de variable para no confundirnos
y voy a tomar que que otra función una
nueva función llamada g es igual a x si
yo tengo que g es igual de xy por lo
tanto pues tengo que sacar la derivada
del coste no de g entonces vamos a poner
lo que es igual a x james por lo tanto
lo que tenemos escrito es el coste no
deje y yo es lo que voy a buscar es la
derivada del coste no deje con respecto
a g es decir la derivada con respecto a
g del coste no deje y bueno ya lo
habíamos mencionado hace rato que la
derivada del coce no es igual al menos
seno entonces tengo el menos
deje pero quieres que busque el axn
entonces menos seno de x de ya esto hay
que multiplicarlo por la derivada de lo
que está adentro es decir de 15 pero con
quién con respecto a x entonces a esto
hay que multiplicarlo por la derivada
con respecto a x lo voy a poner así y al
ratito lo hacemos la derivada con
respecto a x de xy además ya casi no
tengo espacio entonces no creo que me
quepa aquí esta derivada y todo esto es
igual a la derivada de 2 con respecto a
x pero 2 es una constante por lo tanto
no cambia con respecto a x entonces su
derivada es 0 muy bien bueno ahora voy a
resolver la derivada con respecto x que
quedó pendiente aquí entonces vamos a
escribir otra vez todo esto y resuelvo
esta derivada 3g cuadrada que no nos
permiten o no no nos que estoy
confundiendo con lo que les decía hace
rato tres veces ya cuadrada por la
derivada de ya con respecto a x
- y bueno aquí ahora sí voy a
multiplicar el menos menos por 1 y
cuadrada es menos 10 cuadrada y menos
por 2 10 derivadas de 10 con respecto a
x por x es pues menos dos veces que x lo
voy a escribir así es más fácil menos
dos veces x y por las derivadas de que
con respecto x al final siempre estoy
dejando la derivada de con respecto a x
recuerden que tras de eso voy y bueno
menos el seno de x james y ahora si
tengo que hacer la derivada con respecto
a x de x porque entonces es todo esto
multiplicado por una derivada de una
multiplicación de funciones entonces
vamos a hacerlo con calma primero tengo
que derivar a x con respecto a x que
pues es muy sencillo es 1 ya estoy
multiplicarlo por james y después
sumarle la derivada de que con respecto
a x es decir pues la derivada de ella
con respecto a x y multiplicarlo por x
entonces es más la derivada de ella con
respecto a x x la segunda función que
era x
y todo esto es que hicieron paréntesis
todo esto es igual a cero
bueno ahora lo que voy a hacer es
multiplicar el menos seno de xy tanto
porque como por la derivada de yo con
respecto x de x entonces vamos a hacerlo
tres veces y encuadrada por la derivada
de ella con respecto a x menos menos vía
cuadrada
y a esto hay que restarle dos veces x y
la derivada de con respecto a x ya esto
hay que restarle y bueno menos seno de
guille porque es menos seno de que
porsche o dicho de otra manera menos 10
veces el seno de xy muy bien y después
menos seno de xy por la derivada de ye
con respecto a x por x pues es lo mismo
que menos x por la derivada de ella con
respecto a x por el seno de xy y bueno
todo esto tiene que ser igual a cero ok
ahora lo que quiero hacer es juntar los
términos semejantes que tengan que ver
con la derivada de y con respecto a x
quiero despejar la derivada de ella con
respecto x por lo tanto vamos a
factorizar la y me queda la derivada de
ye con respecto a x que multiplica pues
primero a tres de cuadrado después a
menos dos veces x y recuerda el que ella
cuadrada por uno tiene la derivada de
ella con respecto x el que le sigue más
bien el que seguiría sería dos veces x
es éste este término
este término por lo tanto es la derivada
de con respecto de x que multiplica a
tres veces y cuadrada menos dos veces x
james ya esto hay que restarle pues el
último término menos x por el seno de x
- equis veces el seno de x yen y esto
todo esto va a ser igual y ahora me voy
a fijar en los términos que no tenían
que ver con dj de x que era este de aquí
voy a poner otro color era este de aquí
quedó solo y este de aquí también quedó
solo entonces los voy a pasar de una vez
del otro lado de la ecuación si están
con signo negativo van a pasar entonces
con signo positivo fíjense que en este
momento estoy hablando espacio y tiempo
me estoy sintiendo un poco relativista
pero bueno voy a pasar todo del otro
lado con el signo contrario y así va a
ser mucho más fácil que lo veamos
entonces esto es igual a menos de
cuadrada del otro lado pasa como más
cuadrada entonces es cuadrada ya esto
hay que agregarle el otro término es
decir 10 veces el seno de x
estaba con signo negativo y va a pasar
con signo positivo y bueno ahora sí ya
estoy muy cerca de acabar este ejercicio
atrás lo que voy es tras la derivada de
ye gon respecto x es lo que quiero
despejar por lo tanto lo que me estorba
es todo esto de aquí y lo voy a pasar si
está multiplicando dividiendo entonces
voy a agarrar un color llamativo para
poner la respuesta final la derivada de
ya con respecto a x es igual a que
cuadrado más 10 veces el seno de x gem y
todo esto va a estar dividido entre tres
veces y al cuadrado menos dos veces xy
- x veces el seno de x 10 y aquí lo
tienen hemos terminado de resolver este
ejercicio que era un buen ejercicio de
derivación implícita y yo espero que no
haya cometido ningún error sería muy
buen ejercicio para ustedes volver a
hacerlo para ver si llegan a lo mismo y
si no he cometido en ningún error así
que qué bueno que hicimos este problema
y nos vemos en el siguiente